Besides surveys controlled experiments are another important type of research.
Imagine that the researchers are testing the effects of some sleep medication on
a bunch of different people and that these people are random sample. This is as
oppose to the convenient sample in which people who are convenient to find are
used in the study. Everyone receives a pill, but for some, the pill has
medication that supposedly helps you sleep, and for others it's inactive. The
pill looks the same for everybody, and the sample is randomly assigned to one of
the two types of pills. What do you think the purpose was for giving some of the
people in inactive pill? To make sure there are no side effects of the active
pill, to have a comparison group to those who took the active pill or to see if
the inactive pill can help people sleep.Which do you think the purpose was?